Cheers Cheers two hands
I can't fit in my mouth
what's up guys I'm back with another
recipe video always trying to figure out
new ways to impress the wife in the
kitchen and lately I've been loving
taking Chinese food and reimagining them
into more effusion fare and today we are
taking the honey walnut shrimp and
turning it into one of my favorite
sandwiches of all time the po boy now
honey walnut shrimp isn't exactly the
most Chinese dish to begin with it
really is a fusion dish that came out of
Hong Kong where chefs there utilized
Western condiments to create a new
flavor profile and it's mainly eaten
that fancy banquet dinners on the flip
side though there's nothing fancy about
the po boy it literally means poor boy
and it was something that came right out
of the Great Depression and since these
two Origin stories don't have that much
in common other than the shrimp and
mayonnaise I thought why not fuse it
together we're first gonna start by
making the honey walnut shrimp based on
our research honey walnut shrimp was
probably created in the 60s or 70s Hong
Kong and at the time with more access to
Western Products from England they
started using something we call
mayonnaise so we're going to begin with
a quarter cup of mayonnaise
and as the name of this dish would
suggest it's sweet
so we're adding two tablespoons of
condensed milk
[Music]
and one tablespoon of honey and help
balance and bind everything together add
in a quarter teaspoon of rice vinegar
mix it all together and set aside moving
on to our shrimp we'll be using one
pound of shrimp medium size if you want
to use the freshest shrimp by all means
get the heads and everything on it but
I'm going to go ahead and use some
frozen shrimp it's already beheaded
that's not a nice way to save no heads
de-shelled and deveined to season our
shrimp we're going to keep it super
simple half a teaspoon of garlic powder
half a teaspoon of onion powder half a
teaspoon of salt and since we're frying
our shrimp we're gonna need a starch so
we'll be using two tablespoons of corn
starch give the shrimp a good mix with
all the seasonings in there and we're
ready to start frying
now when you fry your shrimp you want to
fry them in batches so to not crowd them
shrimp is quick to cook so I'm probably
only frying for about a minute fry them
until they're pink with the crispy
golden exterior then take out your
shrimp and drain them of any excess oil
transfer them to a mixing bowl and pour
in that mayonnaise sauce in with your
shrimp if you're not familiar with this
dish you might think that this is a
crazy combination and honestly growing
up eating this dish I've always thought
it was a crazy combination never
understood why it actually works but it
does next for texture we're going to add
in half a cup of walnuts and now mix and
toss your ingredients to make sure all
the flavors are worked in together next
we're going to prep our toppings for the
po-boy slice the Tomato shred some
lettuce dice a green onion then take a
loaf of freshly baked french bread and
cut it to whatever length of a cobal you
would want it to be tap it open it up
lay out a bed of lettuce add your tomato
slices and Spoon some of that honey
walnut shrimp onto your po boy and of
course make sure to include the walnuts
for an extra Crunch and finally top it
off with some green onions and there you
have honey walnut shrimp po boy
[Music]
I'm pretty good
I'm running my shrimp
that's really yummy I like doing this
actually worked out
[Music]
that one got away and kind of want it
yet
the game changer
[Music]
I'm extra crunchy
this actually worked I didn't think it
would work really it's like
so sweet you know I don't know if that's
normal with the lettuce tomatoes yeah
the lettuce is all like fresh and the
tomatoes are like fresh and then the
bread kind of like
counteracts your counter or what is it
our balances with the sweetness there's
a lot of fun textures too
next time I'm gonna make the shrimp more
Cajun really flavor I think it's perfect
yeah don't touch it I love it
now the green onions were needed yeah
she just finished get going
running errands and stuff and I was like
oh I forgot the green onions can you
bring that back real quick yes it was
very needed
what's this song made of mayonnaise
condensed milk and honey and a little
bit of rice vinegar I actually grew up
eating this one it was like
party foods like banquet foods and then
just served like that you have a rice I
like it like this this one was totally
wifey approved this combination was
definitely better than expected I would
highly recommend this if I ever made a
cooking book out of all these recipes
I'm making this would definitely be in
that book and texture is your thing this
sandwich has got it all those walnuts
definitely give it an extra crunch if
you want to see more cooking videos in
the future make sure to hit like And
subscribe alright until next time peace
every time you're going with your family
I've never once seen Manny's
my dad hates this dish
do you think I like this one
probably not
[Music]